- [Mark Lait] All right, Fillmore Slim,
Fillmore, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Fillmore Slim] Louisiana.
- [Mark Laita] What city?
- [Fillmore Slim] Baton Rouge
- [Mark Lait] Baton
Rouge. And tell me about
your childhood, you had both your
parents when you were a kid?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh, when I was a kid,
I'd come up to Louisiana, you know and
both my parents, you know they
hard worker.
My daddy worked on the train,
my mama worked at the bank.
And in Louisiana, come up as just a
little kid in Louisiana, enjoying
life, you know?
Had to work, you know?
- [Mark Lait] Good childhood then?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well yeah I was
working for these drug stores,
and liquor stores.
- [Mark Lait] So, did you have role-models
that kinda lead you down this path
that your life took?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh, yeah I've got a lot
of role-models, all over the world,
yeah you know I'm, I'm
the godfather, you know?
Even the hip-hop people, you know?
Snoop, Ice-T, all them, you know they,
they honor me.
- [Mark Lait] Yeah you're recognized
as the, the godfather of this game.
What age were you when you first
got started as a pimp?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh, see pimping wasn't
my thing, music was my thing, see?
I started off wanting to be a
entertainer, you know I watched big
big stars on the stage like B.B. King
and all those type of people, you know
Lloyd Price and all them.
So, and all the woman screaming
and hollering and everything, so I didn't
know about no pimping.
So, that's what I wanted to be,
I said well, I'm gonna be an entertainer
and all that and I'll have all
the woman screaming and hollering at me,
looking at me on stage. That was my goal,
but the pimping, that wasn't my thing
you know I didn't know I was gonna
be no pimp man, you know?
- [Mark Lait] So, how
did that happen then?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well I
happened to be traveling
on the road playing music, living in
Los Angeles, on this tour and we stopped
in a little town called Midland Texas,
and when we stopped in this town
called Midland Texas, we was making
about $10 a night.
- [Mark Lait] What year was this?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh we
would say in the 50's,
say '54, '55.
- [Mark Lait] You're 80, how old are you?
- [Fillmore Slim] I'm 85.
- [Mark Lait] You're 85?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah, so at this time
we were performing and right next to
this club, there was a hotel and the
name of this crib was
called a White Front,
and it was right there in Midland Texas.
So, as I'm playing, I'm playing the blues
and I'm playing piano, and like I said
we're making $10 a night and I noticed
this chick right, had her own setup
and she keeps going out, coming back,
going out and coming back.
So, I didn't know what was going on,
so in about five days, I was sitting
on the piano and she comes up
and she says, "Here."
I say, "What is this?" She says,
"That's for you."
So, I thought it was
like a big tip, right?
So, I put the money in my pocket,
and she kept doing this, right?
So, the fellas in the band say,
"Man, that's a prostitute." And they
said, "You know, we don't need
to be associating with her."
I said, "Man, she gave me a little
money every night, we only making about
$10 a night, I'm going to take the money."
So, we did this about, she did this about,
maybe about a week.
And I looked up, I had about, oh man
close to about $125, and that was a
bank roll done in about '55, '56.
So, we're all ready to back to L.A.
They told me, no, first I asked
I said, "What you do?"
She said, "I go to bed
with men for money."
I said, "Well what is that?"
She said, "They pay me money, I go to
bed with them." So, I still didn't know,
then she explained it to me about what
it was, she was selling sex, okay?
So, me being green, you know not
knowing what's going on, all I
was doing was playing music, singing
the blues. So, when we got ready
to go back to L.A. she had a little
suitcase packed. She said,
"I wanna go with you."
I said, "Why?"
I said, "What's your husband gonna say?"
She said, "I ain't got no husband."
So, the fellas in band said,
"Man, that's a prostitute, we ain't gonna
take her back to L.A. you know?
I said, "Man, check this out, I'm
getting $10 a night." Looking at
my little bank roll. I said,
"She going with me." I said,
"Matter of fact, it's my van, so
if y'all don't wanna go, y'all
catch the bus." So, I brought her
back to Los Angeles, right there
on Vernon and Central, you know?
And stayed at a, right above a
fast food restaurant called Coney Island.
So, she said "Well, show me where
the girls work." I said,
"Right there on the corner."
They had a big record store there,
the same one that Rudy Ray Moore used to
work in called Dolphin's Of Hollywood.
So, I told her where the girls work at
and she went out there and she came
back, the second night she came back,
she had another girl with her.
I said, "Well, who is that?
She said, "That's our wife in-law."
I said, "I ain't married."
She say, "But in the game, she's with us."
So, now I got two girls.
So now, I'm playing guitar there
and I put the guitar in the corner,
and now they start calling me for jobs
around L.A. and I told them that
somebody else must play in my place.
I had two girls on the corner,
so I was getting paid, you know?
- [Mark Lait] What kind of girls?
Black girls, white girls, Hispanics?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well, I had different.
- [Mark Lait] Different ones?
- [Fillmore Slim] Different girls.
- [Mark Lait] Then, you would have
sex with the girls?
- [Fillmore Slim] Huh?
- [Mark Lait] You would
have sex with the girls?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well, you couldn't
have too much sex with
the girls, you know?
You see with girls, the game is a mind
thing, you know? And if the girls
go out and turn dates and things like that
and they come in, they tired, you know?
So, you know you didn't have to
have too much sex.
And then if you had a girl, she would
have to be with you at least six months
before you even went to bed with her.
- [Mark Lait] Were drugs part of the
game back there?
- [Fillmore Slim] Drugs was in the game
but I wouldn't buy, I wouldn't buy drugs.
- [Mark Lait] Your girls would use
drugs sometimes but you,
you weren't involved?
- [Fillmore Slim] Huh?
- [Mark Lait] Your girls would use
drugs sometimes?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh, I had one girl
who was using drugs, you know but-
- [Mark Lait] It's not your thing?
- [Fillmore Slim] She got a way with men.
- [Mark Lait] Yeah?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah.
- [Mark Lait] Have you done prison time?
- [Fillmore Slim] Huh?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh yeah, yeah I did.
I bought a United States passport,
I did five years.
- [Mark Lait] Yeah? Have you been married?
- [Fillmore Slim] Huh?
- [Mark Lait] Have you been married?
- [Fillmore Slim] I've
been married three times.
They said, "Three strikes, you're out."
- [Mark Lait] It's hard to do this
and be married at the same time,
I would think.
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah.
- [Mark Lait] And then, do you have kids?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh yeah, I've got
17 kids, 15 grandkids, eight or nine,
ten, twelve great-grandkids
- [Mark Lait] So, what is the origin
of pimping? You know they say its
the oldest profession, or prostitution
is the oldest-
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah, in
the bible, from the bible.
- [Mark Lait] What do you think
the origin of this pimping thing was?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well, for me it was
fascinating, you know? It was fashion,
you know? And you get all this money
every night, you know fresh money
every night, you know?
And I thought I was the king of sunset.
Let's say I did all mine on Sunset
down in Los Angeles.
- [Mark Lait] Oh, is that right?
- [Fillmore Slim] That's where I got
all my fame from, L.A.
- [Mark Lait] Now, there's a story
that goes around L.A. that the first time
you came to L.A-
- [Fillmore Slim] I
sent my game down there.
- [Mark Lait] Yeah and they-
- [Fillmore Slim] And the girls, sent
them right there and-
- [Mark Lait] And then the cops gave you
a hard time?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah, oh yeah.
- [Mark Lait] And they
arrested all your girls?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah,
arrested all my girls.
- [Mark Lait] And what
happened after that?
- [Fillmore Slim] Now the story was,
when I first went to L.A. the pimp,
this pimp took all my girls.
- [Mark Lait] Oh, is that what happened?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah it
was a pimp, not the cops.
- [Mark Lait] Okay, the story gets
changed over the years?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah, so the pimp took
all my girls and by me being fresh down
there, you know? And they getting in
the cars and they drove
up to me on Sunset,
I'll never forget that, right across
we sitting there buying this chicken.
Okay, they drove up sunset, he said,
"These your girls?" I said,
"Yeah, they're my girls."
They said, "Not no more."
He said, "They gave me your money
so they with me now."
So, what they did, they said,
"Well, I guess you done lost all your game
so you may as well go
home back to Frisco."
You know? I said,
"No I'm going to the telephone."
So, I went to the telephone and I called
them troopers, you know what I'm saying?
Then they must turn out.
Call the troopers in and they came in.
I said, "Y'all." And then I told them
I said what to do, I said
"Fly to LAX, rent a limousine and come
down here and represent me."
I told them where I was,
and when the limousine
came up and the dogs stepped out,
So all the pimps said,
"Man, who's all them women?"
I said, "They mine."
I said, "If you kiss
them, I'll leave town."
- [Mark Lait] So, the
girls that they stole
were you second stringers?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh yeah.
- [Mark Lait] And the ones you flew down
were your first stringers?
- [Fillmore Slim] Oh, when I send in them
troopers?
- [Mark Lait] Yeah?
- [Fillmore Slim] Yeah.
- [Mark Lait] (laughs)
That's a great story.
So, how has the game changed since
you were doing it? Because
the game has changed-
- [Fillmore Slim] Well,
the game changed now,
there's no respect, you know?
We were like gentleman
of leisure, you know?
We didn't beat our women, you know?
And make them go out there,
you know that starts in prison.
My thing I'll meet a lady and
if she was interested in my proposition,
then we went with it, but no force,
none of that, you know?
The woman love me today and the people
love me today, you know I go around to
schools, I talk to young
people in the schools.
I go to churches, I
talk with young people.
I've been to a couple
of colleges, you know
a couple of young people, and this is
what I explain to them, what we did
in our day, we having our folks parents,
our grandmothers and things.
You know we live in the projects, so what
we did in our day, that's
what we were about.
But now they've got to have young people,
you've got computers, you've got a black
president and all that's been done.
But in our time, I wouldn't have
an electrical type-writer, you know
I wouldn't buy computers
or nothing like this.
So, I tell them, "You've got a better
opportunity than what we had, I don't
condone youngin's going into the game.
I've got a daughter graduating from U.S.C.
I've got a son who is a paramedic.
I've got another son who's
going to Chico State.
We did what we had to do.
- [Mark Lait] What's
more important to you,
love or money?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well,
money. I was growing up
with money and I was in the game
so, I love money. But
what's so good about it,
that I like about it, I could always
fall back on my music.
You see when I got out that life,
I cleaned my life for a minute there.
I was able to pick up my guitar
and play the blues.
You know I put a record out there now,
that's number five in the world.
And then I got all kinds
of awards, inducted
in the blues hall of
fame, B.B. King, you know?
So, I was successful in
the game 150 trophies
as the godfather in the game and in the
hall of fame in the music.
So, that's why my book says, "Blues man,
Michael G. Fillmore Slim, high-talk
of the stage and the streets."
- [Mark Lait] What personality trait
helped you most as a pimp?
- [Fillmore Slim] What personality?
Well, I've always been
a ladies man, you know
I always was a charmer.
I could charm any chick.
I could stop any chick. I'll tell you
a story, I remember I went
by the Chinese theater,
I just came back and I
seen this Caucasian lady
all dressed in white,
walking down sunset, okay?
No, Hollywood Boulevard
right by the Chinese,
and I stopped the car and went around this
little alley right there, you know
before you get to the Chinese theater,
so I came around just so she crossed
that alley, I pull up, I blocked her
I said, "Baby." She said, "What?"
I said, "Here's your
car, this is your car."
She said, "What you mean?" I said,
"It's all white, red inside, this
car came for you." And
she was so fascinated.
I said, "Get in." Spin around, she got
in the car, come to find out we rode
and talk, come to find out she was
O.J. Reynolds. Tobacco king, it was
his granddaughter.
You know and we talked and when I find
that out, you know I told her to have
a good day.
- [Mark Lait] What do you think
the core of the pimp and
prostitute relationship
is? Do you think the
girls are looking for a
man in their life, a
boyfriend, a father figure?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well I think-
- [Mark Lait] They call you guys daddy?
- [Fillmore Slim] Some of the girls I
had, I think, I was like a father figure
to them, I would say,
yeah I would say that.
- [Mark Lait] What's the craziest thing
you've seen in all your years of doing it?
- [Fillmore Slim] The
craziest things I've seen?
I've seen a pimp running a hoe down
Sunset Boulevard and the cops behind them.
(laughs) Yeah, started off at Wilcox and
they chased them all the
way down to (indistinct)
from the city to the county.
- [Mark Lait] And what's
the most important
lesson you learned, in your life?
- [Fillmore Slim] Well the most important
lesson I've learned in my life is if you
play, you're gonna pay.
It ain't always light at
the end of the tunnel.
So we was having fun, fancy clothes, fancy
jewelry, fancy cars.
But you know at the end, you going.
Let's just say you might
get the wrong female,
the law says it takes two.
You get the wrong female and
there's the one that they scare,
you gone.
Look what they do in Vegas.
The guys sent all them players and put
them in penitentiary.
But see we stayed out the penitentiary,
see I had good lawyers,
I had William Brown.
You know he was the house speaker
and he was my lawyer.
- [Mark Lait] He kept you out of jail?
kept you out of prison?
- [Fillmore Slim] That's right.
- [Mark Lait] So, how
many girls did you have
at the peak?
- [Fillmore Slim] I had 23 girls walking
up and down Sunset all the way from Hobart
to Beverly Hills, the Beverly Hills Hotel.
- [Mark Lait] 23 girls? So how much money
did you make from having-
- [Fillmore Slim] Well
it varies, some come
in and may have five, you
know 500, some had 250.
When you add it all up,
it was a lot of money.
- [Mark Lait] Yeah.
- [Fillmore Slim] But
I wanna say this here,
I wasn't no gold digger
pimp, I was a gentleman,
I would call myself
gentleman of leisure and
that's why the woman love me today.
I walked down the street, they wanna take
a picture with me, I
walk down the street by
UC Berkeley, all the students came out
wanted to take a picture with me.
And the police rode by and looked,
I say eat your heart out.
All right.
- [Mark Lait] All right
Fillmore Slim, thank you
so much for talking with me.
- [Fillmore Slim] All right then.
- [Mark Lait] Thank you.
- [Fillmore Slim] And I
wanna say one more thing.
- [Mark Lait] Oh sure, let's hear it.
- [Fillmore Slim] Okay
now, me, we on the Roger
team now, me, Divine
Brown and Gangsta Brown
and Kenny Red, we are artists.
Bishop is church, we are artists.